it's crazy it was like four against me
because there were some conservatives on
the panel but there were no real
conservatives no real red pillars like
it was like more people that are kind of
in the middle or me I'm like a Die Hard
another thing that came up I didn't talk
as much about this as I wanted to
they're talking about beauty standards
and I'm like I'm sorry I'm sorry I've
had hundreds of videos made about me
calling me ugly I don't let those get to
you you cannot make it an excuse that
you saw the Kardashians growing up and
that made you feel bad about yourself
you you you let people make you feel bad
that is a choice you can choose to let
it get to you or choose to just say you
know
I'm a I'm a bad and there ain't
you can do to make me mad